ON THE NEW HABIT OF DEMOCRATS.
IT'S CALLED DUCKING DEBATES AND
GIVING THE PERFORMANCES OF THOSE
WHO SHOW UP IT'S NOT HARD TO SEE
WHY.
LAST NIGHT IN OHIO BETWEEN
REPUBLICAN J.D. VANCE AND
DEMOCRATIC TIM RYAN.
RYAN CLAIMS TO BE A MAN OF THE
PEOPLE.
HE SPENT HIS CAREER IN PUBLIC
OFFICER MAKING THEIR LIVES
WORSE.
INSTEAD OF OWNING UP TO THE
LIES.
>> I HAVE BEEN A NATURAL GAS
PROPONENT SINCE I WAS IN
CONGRESS.
>> TIM RYAN JUST TOLD A BIG FIB.
TWO YEARS AGO YOU SUPPORTED
BANNING FRACKING.
>> Laura: BINGO.
RYAN DIDN'T JUST SELLOUT HIS
CONSTITUENTS ON HIGH ENERGY
PRICES BUT SENT THEIR JOBS
OVERSEAS.
>> TIM RYAN, EXPLAIN WHY THE GUY
HAD HIS CONGRESSIONAL DISTRICT
LOSE TENS OF THOUSANDS OF JOBS
TO CHINA.
>> Laura: TIM RYAN NEEDED TO
PULL OFF AT THAT POINT.
THAT WASN'T THE MOST EFFECTIVE
TAKE DOWN.
THERE ARE WERE MORE.
TIM RYAN THOUGHT HE HAD VANCE
OVER THE ROPES OVER ONE ISSUE:
ABORTION.
AFTER CLAIMING THAT VANCE WOULD
NOT SUPPORT ABORTION IN THE RAPE
OF A YOUNG GIRL, WHICH IS A LIE.
HE REFUSED TO EXPLAIN THE
BACKGROUND OF THE TRAGIC STORY.
ENTER VANCE.
>> WHY WAS A 10-YEAR-OLD RAPED
IN OUR STATE IN THE FIRST PLACE.
THEY NEVER MENTION THAT POOR
GIRL WAS RAPED BY AN ILLEGAL
ALLEN.
YOU VOTED AGAINST BORDER WALL
FUNDING AND IF HAD YOU HAD DONE
YOUR JOB SHE WOULD HAVE NEVER
BEEN RAPED.
DO YOUR JOB ON BORDER
SECURITY --
>> Laura: IT'S NOT ENOUGH TO
POINT OUT THE LIES.
WHY ARE THE DEMOCRATS EXCUSING
POLICIES THAT ALLOW THIS EVIL TO
OCCUR IN OUR COMMUNITIES?
THE TIME FOR DEFENSIVE
CANDIDATES IS OVER.
JOINING ME NOW IS J.D. VANCE
SENATE CANDIDATE IN OHIO.
I DIDN'T GET TO WATCH THIS LIVE.
I WATCHED IT ONLINE.
IT SEEMED LIKE YOU WERE HAVING
FUN UP THERE.
WERE YOU ACTING?
I ENJOYED IT.
>> I WAS DEFINITELY HAVING FUN.
THANKS FOR HAVING ME.
I LISTENED TO 4 MONTHS FOR THIS
GUY TO TELL LIES ABOUT MY RECORD
AND LIES ABOUT HIS RECORD.
IT WAS A GREAT OPPORTUNITY TO
CORRECT THAT RECORD AND TELL THE
TRUTH ABOUT WHAT A COMPLETE
FRAUD THIS GUY IS.
100% VOTING WITH JOE BIDEN AND
NANCY PELOSI.
PRETENDS TO BE A MODERATE.
I RELISHED THE OPPORTUNITY TO
GET IN THE RING WITH HIM AND
SHAKE THINGS UP.
>> Laura: HE SEEMED AT SEVERAL
POINTS DURING THE DEBATE LIKE
HEHAD TO PASS A KIDNEY STONE.
HE HAD AN INTERESTING TAKE AWAY.
>> BY ALL ACCOUNTS WE WON THE
DEBATE.
GOT A LOT OF PEOPLE WANTING TO
SUPPORT THE CAMPAIGN NOW.
MITCH MCCONNELL GAVE HIM $4
MILLION AND PETER TEAL 15.
IT'S DAVID VERSUS GOLIATH BUT WE
HAVE A GOOD SHOT TO WIN.
>> Laura: I AM TRYING TO FIGURE
THIS OUT.
HE IS TRYING TO PAINT HIMSELF AS
AN OUTDOOR.
-- OUTSIDER?
[LAUGHING]?
>> YES, HE TELLS WHOPPER AFTER
WHOPPER.
THE NATIONAL DEMOCRATIC PARTY
POURED TENS OF MILLION DOLLARS
INTO THIS RACE.
HE RUNS AWAY FROM HIS RECORD AND
PRETENDS HE IS A MODERATE.
ON HIS TV COMMERCIALS YOU WOULD
THINK HE WAS A RIGHT WING
CONSERVATIVE BECAUSE HIS RECORD
IS NONEXISTENT.
HE'S BEEN IN CONGRESS FOR 20
YEARS AND GOT NOTHING
SIGNIFICANT ACCOMPLISHED FOR HIS
DISTRICT.
HE IS THE PORTER BOY -- POSTER
BOY OF FAILING.
I DON'T THINK OHIO WILL FALL FOR
IT.
>> Laura: I DON'T EITHER?
>> YOU SHOWED REPUBLIC